BRETT HESTERBERG: Welcome
to Google Cloud on air.
In this session,
we'll be talking
about high availability
and disaster
recovery with Cloud SQL.
My name is Brad Hesterberg.
I'm a product manager
working on Cloud SQL.
And while we can't
see each other today,
I do hope to learn a little bit
about you in part of this talk.
If you're comfortable
doing so, please
use your chat window
or your question window
to let me know your job
title-- are you a DBA?
A reluctant DBA?
DevOps engineer, developer,
or something else?
And which relational
database you use most often.
Is it MySQL, SQL server,
Oracle, postgreSQL, Sybase, DB2,
SQLite, or something else?
Hopefully, we can
still get a chance
to get to know each
other a little bit.
And as a note, I'll be available
as part of Google Cloud Next
Expert Sessions if
you would like to meet
with me about Cloud SQL.
Today, we're going to be
talking about concepts
related to high availability
and disaster recovery.
We'll start off a little bit
with the concepts themselves,
and go over some terminology.
From there, we'll talk about how
we protect against user error,
and then get into how we might
achieve high availability,
especially with Cloud SQL.
And lastly, we'll
round out with what
to do when we have a disaster.
How do we recover?
So to start, I'll give a
little bit of information
about Cloud SQL itself.
SQL is a managed
database service
that offers MySQL,
postgreSQL, and SQL server.
This means that if
your application works
with MySQL, SQL
server, postgreSQL,
it works with Cloud SQL.
Compatibility is
at our core, and we
focus on managing the
mundane aspects of database
administration.
When I think about database
administration, what
it takes to run a
database, this tends
to be the diagram that I
think of in the left hand
column, or leftmost column,
we see server maintenance,
racking stacking servers,
HVAC networking power, things
related to managing
a data center
or managing a
server environment,
the hardware itself.
Of course, in the cloud, this
is taken care of for you.
And in Cloud SQL, with
our SQL instances,
we ensure that when you
configure a number of VCBUs
and some RAM, that you
get a consistent instance,
regardless of as
to what's happening
with your underlying hardware.
We make sure that that
instance continues forward,
even when we have
hardware changes going on.
Looking a little further
to the right on the slide,
we see the column that talks
about the operating system.
And this includes installing
the operating system,
as well as patching it,
keeping it up to date.
Right, one more from
there, finally, we
get to the database
itself, where
we're installing the database.
We're keeping it
patched and up to date.
And the last thing we're
thinking about, protecting
our data with a set of backups.
Finally, on the
slide right most, we
get into high
availability, usually
using replication and
some health checking
to perhaps, perform automatic
fail failover in the event
we have an incident or an
outage, and also scaling.
Thinking about things like
using replication to scale
out reads, for example.
We wrap up this entire
technology stack in monitoring,
so that if there
is a problem, we're
able to understand
where the root cause is.
And Cloud SQL's
job here is to take
this, what is usually a complex
technology stack, and wrap it
in an API and a UI, so that your
developers or your application
teams are able to easily turn
up a dev or test database,
or even a much more complex
production database, which
includes automatic failover
for high availability,
built-in backups
for data protection,
and near real time copies
of data in other regions,
in case of a regional failure
or an actual disaster.
Our customer, Tim Kelton,
at Descartes Labs I think,
sums this up pretty well.
He says for his team,
Cloud SQL gives him
more time to work on the
products that provide value
to their customers.
What Tim is saying is they
would rather spend time
on products that are
meaningful to their customers
than on the mundane aspects
of database administration.
And Tim's team uses Cloud
SQL to help offset that time.
One thing that we should
note is that Cloud SQL
is backed by a 24 by 7 SRE team,
Site Reliability Engineering
team.
This is the team that
writes the automation
to make sure our databases are
healthy, our service runs well.
And in the event
of a problem that
can't be solved by
automation, they're
the folks who get
hands-on keyboard to bring
a database back to life.
As we talk about high
availability and disaster
recovery, it's important
to start with a little bit
of terminology.
To begin, we'll
talk about backups.
Backups are independent
copies of the data set
that isn't in the
database serving path.
This means we think about the
database's data set, the data
it's working on right now.
We usually make a copy of
it-- an independent copy--
sent to some other
storage system
so that that backup is no
longer in the serving path
or the place where the
database is making changes
to the primary data set.
In Cloud SQL, we offer
automated backups,
which means we take
them daily for example,
at a time that you set.
We also offer on-demand or
manual backups, where you
can tell us to take a backup.
And we'll take it in that one.
Going beyond backups, we get
to point-in-time recovery.
Point-in-time recovery
is functionality that
often uses backups to restore to
a very granular point in time,
down to, for example,
the millisecond.
As part of
point-in-time recovery,
usually we keep transaction logs
which contain a list or a log
of all transactions the
database has been running--
all the inserts,
updates, et cetera--
so that we can go back to
very granular points in time,
specific moments when
a transaction was
run, for example.
Also on the list is replication.
Replication is a continuous
copy of data from your source
or your primary
database to a replica
or a secondary database.
This means that we
are making sure we
have either a real time
or a near real time
copy of data in some other
database from your primary.
Replication has
two major options.
One is synchronous.
The other is asynchronous.
In a synchronous
replication model,
a transaction is
not fully committed
or is not responded to by the
primary instance to a client
until both the primary database
instance and its replica
have committed the transaction.
The primary instance
will wait for the replica
to ensure that both have
committed the transaction
before it responds to the
client saying your transaction
has now been committed.
In asynchronous replication,
the primary instance
doesn't wait for the replica.
In this case, the
primary instance
simply commits the transaction.
And without waiting
for the replica
to let it know that it too
committed the transaction,
it responds to the client
saying your transaction has
been committed.
We'll talk about
how Cloud SQL uses
both of these as part of its
availability and disaster
recovery protection mechanisms.
The last two terms
that we'll go over here
are recovery point objective
and recovery time objective.
Recovery point objective
is the maximum time period
in which we might lose data from
our system due to an incident.
Spoken plainly,
this means that when
we take a backup right now, we
allow the database to continue
to run.
So our backup in
this very moment
has the exact data
set our database does.
We have a full copy,
an independent copy,
of the data set from right now.
But the database continues to
perform inserts and updates,
changing the data set
subsequent to our backup.
Now there's data in
the database that we
don't have in our backup.
If we were to have an incident
losing our database right now,
we would lose all of
the transactions that
were committed after
we took our backup.
When we talk about a
recovery point objective,
we're setting an
objective which states
we are only wanting to lose
a particular amount of data.
So for example, if our
RPO were five minutes,
we would ensure that we
have a data protection
mechanism in place
such that we would not
lose more than five minutes
of transactions for example,
from one backup to the next.
This is depicted in the
diagram on the slide
as a backup, which
is 0.1, and then
an incident happening roughly
in the middle of the diagram.
The difference or the
timeline between the backup
and the incident is--
it helps us define our recovery
point objective effectively
quantifies how much data
we've lost in that incident.
Recovery time objective is
the targeted duration of time
that we allow to recover
the data that has previously
been backed up.
What this means is in
the event of an incident,
when we want to use one of
our data protection mechanisms
to recover data, we
measure the amount of time
it takes to perform the recovery
from the backup as an example,
and get the database
back up and running.
That amount of time is
known as our recovery time.
And we set an
objective which states
how much time we will allow
for that process to happen.
In a critical database
system, usually the RPO,
recovery point objective, and
RTO are pretty small values.
Recovery point objective
perhaps, measured in seconds.
And recovery time objective
perhaps, measured in minutes.
In less critical systems
or non-critical databases,
these objectives may
be much more lenient,
with recovery point
objectives being much larger
and recovery time
objectives being longer,
or allowing more data loss
and more recovery time.
And we define how we protect
data-- the mechanisms we use,
the number of protections
we put in place--
to try to adhere to
our RPO and our RTO.
Let's talk about protecting
against user error.
In presentations
like these, often we
talk mostly about disasters.
And we depict them with
lightning bolts or fire
on the slides.
In reality, much more
common that human error
is the culprit of data loss.
We ourselves, in some
sense, are the disaster.
Perhaps I make a mistake, I
drop a table, change a row,
and I didn't mean to.
I want to get back in time.
I want to undo that change.
And I may not know,
by the way, that I
made a mistake for a
couple hours, for example.
How do we protect against
that kind of user error, which
is far more common in
enterprise IT environments
or any IT environment?
Cloud SQL, I talked
about using backups.
In Cloud SQL, as mentioned,
offers both automated backups,
as well as on demand backups.
In the screenshot,
we show a user
configuring automated backups
where the user is setting
a time, when we take
a backup automatically
via Cloud SQL once per day.
With these backups,
it's important to note
that these are storage-level
or block-level backups,
so that we are minimizing
the amount of data
that we are tracking
between backups,
or that we are saving
to another system.
If we take a backup
at this moment,
we watch and track the
number of block changes
to the next time we
take a backup, which
means the size of backups--
and common question
from customers
is, how large will
my backups be--
it is more dependent
on how busy or active
your database is, than
on how frequently you
take these backups.
For example, a very
active database
will generate quite large backup
files, lots of block changes,
from one backup to the next,
whereas a largely inactive
database will generate many
changes between backups.
And even if we take
backups quite frequently,
they might be very small.
You can imagine a database
not doing any work right now.
If we take a backup
and wait a few seconds
and then take another
one, the second backup
may be extremely
small, because we
didn't have any subsequent block
changes between the backups.
How can we do a little
better than backups?
If we're taking
backups each day,
that might mean we
have a recovery point
objective of roughly 24
hours, where our worst case is
that if we take a backup
yesterday at 11:00 PM,
we have a problem
today at 10:59 PM,
almost exactly 24 hours
since our last backup,
but about a minute before
we take the next backup.
How can we do better than this?
This is where point-in-time
recovery comes into play.
As I mentioned, point-in-time
recovery builds upon backups,
or uses backups usually as
part of the recovery mechanism.
Here, we're showing a screenshot
of setting up or rather,
recovering using point-in-time
recovery in Cloud SQL.
What you see here is that
we're using a timestamp based
point-in-time.
Here, we're selecting
down to the millisecond
when we want to recover
to it in the past.
Cloud SQL offers transaction
or timestamp-based recovery
with point-in-time
recovery back seven days.
So it allows me to
pick a millisecond
in any of the last seven days
to which I want to recover to.
This means that if I've made
a mistake, as I described
earlier, I might want to go
to the millisecond or even
the second before I
made that mistake.
And in this example,
we're cloning or copying
a database to that point.
So I can go back and get
that data, bring it back
into my primary database,
effectively undoing
the mistake that I made.
With backup protections
or data protections
rather, in mind,
let's now take a look
at how to achieve
high availability.
As a starting
point, you all have
worked in IT environments
for a long time.
And you know that high
availability is not
easy to achieve it
usually involves
some combination of replication,
health checking, and then
some workflow
management, in case
we want to automatically
fail failover
in the event of an incident.
With high availability,
we usually
begin by talking
about data redundancy.
High availability often
relies on writing data
to two or more places
so that in case
of an incident with our
primary database instance,
we have the data
elsewhere, and are quickly
able to make it available to
recover from that incident.
This type of configuration is
sometimes called a cluster.
It simply means we're using
two or more database servers
to perform the
tasks that one could
perform so that
we have redundancy
in case of an incident.
For Cloud SQL, it's important to
note that the high availability
configuration is required
for SLA coverage.
Our service level
agreement for SLA
guarantees a particular uptime.
And as part of that SLA, we
require that high availability
is enabled so that we can
automatically and quickly
recover from any incident
that may affect your database
instance.
When we talk about high
availability in Cloud SQL,
this is conceptually
what it looks like.
When the high availability
configuration is enabled,
we create a primary
instance in the zone
and a standby instance
in another zone.
In this example, we've created
a primary instance in zone A,
and a standby instance
in zone B. This
ensures that we have redundancy
in our HA configuration
such that if there's
a problem in zone A,
we have a place to failover
to, and an instance that we
can bring up quickly
to recover and be back
online for our client.
Also shown in the diagram
is that we're writing data
to two places at once.
We're using a regional
persistent disk,
which synchronicity
replicates data
in both zones-- in this
case, zone A and zone B.
So before the primary
database instance
will confirm to a client that a
transaction has been committed,
it ensures that the data has
been written to both zones
when our system is
operating normally.
This means that we can reliably
failover to our standby zone
knowing we have a full
copy of the data set,
and every last
committed transaction
will be present when we bring
the database back online.
In case of an outage,
Cloud SQL does
a number of things from
a workflow perspective.
Most important to
note is that we
move the IP address and the
name of the primary instance
to the standby instance.
This is important because
an application then need not
know about the failover itself.
It only has to try to reconnect,
because the IP address
doesn't change.
To the application,
it simply looks
like the database has gone
down and then has come back up.
And by retrying,
the application can
reconnect and begin
serving traffic just
after the failover.
To get used or to
get comfortable
with Cloud SQL's high
availability configuration,
I recommend that
you get hands-on.
You can check it out for
yourself in the product.
And you can initiate a failover.
In the UI, you'll see a
failover button or VR API.
You can also take a
look at our code lapse.
We have a code lab
in particular that
features Kubernetes
Engine in Cloud SQL,
and it talks about how you
can build a fault tolerance
application, where
in the lab, you
will test fault tolerance both
in the application layer--
Kubernetes engine-- as
well as in Cloud SQL.
Lastly, I encourage you
to check out this showcase
that we've created for
Google Cloud Next 2020.
This showcase is essentially
a whack-a-mole of databases
where you can see how many times
you can make Cloud SQL fail
and how many times it recovers
by kind of whack-a-mole style
taking down the database,
perhaps in zone A
and seeing it pop back up
in zone B. The link is shown
in the slide.
And I encourage
you to take a look.
Let's round out with
a look at recovering
in case of a large disaster.
In here, you and your
careers have likely
spent a lot of time
planning and even testing
for large disasters.
Hopefully, you haven't
faced many real ones.
In Google terms, when
we think of a disaster,
we tend to think of this
as a regional outage, where
a region is comprised of
usually three or more zones,
independent failure domains.
And this would mean
something has happened such
that all the zones or enough
of the zones in a region
are down, that the region
does not have connectivity.
It is totally down.
As you can imagine, this
has significant consequences
as any disaster would.
When you're doing your
disaster recovery planning,
you're imagining
usually that most
of the applications,
if not all that
serve your internal users
and your external customers,
may be down.
And in that moment,
the job is to make sure
that we can recover quickly
and perform the recovery such
that we lose a
minimum set of data.
A stressful moment, to be sure.
Let's look at how
Cloud SQL has tried
to make this a little easier.
We've introduced cross
region replication
to help guard against
regional failure.
It allows you to
have a near real time
copy via a replica in one
or more regions outside
of your primary region.
We're relying on
Google's network,
including Google Cloud
VPC, or virtual networks,
so that you have
a very private way
to connect between
your primary instance
and it's replicas
in other regions.
Further, because
Google's VPCs are global,
there's a very minimal
network configuration for you
to perform here.
The Google VPC spans all
regions in the cloud network,
all of the regions you're
using, which makes this very
easy to use and to configure.
In fact, you see in
the screenshot here
highlighted all we're
doing is selecting
a region, other than
our primary region,
when we're creating a replica.
And we can be certain that
the replica is being spun up
in another region, and we're
connecting from our primary
to our replicate in
a very secure fashion
over our private network.
With the replica now
deployed in another region,
let's look at what's actually
happening behind the scenes.
In this diagram, you see a
high availability configuration
in a primary region.
In this case, US Central 1.
Here again, we're using
synchronous replication
within the region to ensure
that we can automatically
failover without losing
committed transactions.
Between regions or outside
of the primary region
to your replicas, we're using
asynchronous replication.
As you recall from our
terminology section,
asynchronous replication means
the primary instance is not
waiting for the replicas to
commit their transactions
before it tells the client the
transaction has been committed.
We do that because
the latency can
be higher between regions,
given the geographic distance
between them.
We don't want to
harm performance
in the primary region by
waiting for every replica
around the world to say I also
have committed the transaction.
And so we replicate
asynchronously.
This has ramifications for
your recovery point objective.
It means that you
can potentially
have replication lag, usually
on the order of seconds,
but your replica doesn't
have the exact real time
copy of the data
set the primary has.
It has a near real time copy--
something that's perhaps a few
seconds in the past from what
has now happened on
the primary instance.
Bear this in mind, especially
in your disaster recovery plan.
In this diagram though, we
see two replicas-- again,
these could be in any
regions in the world,
even in separate regions--
allowing us to ensure that
we have a very near real time
copy of data elsewhere.
And that allows us, from an
RTO, recovery time objective
perspective, in case
of a regional outage
of our primary region, to
offer roughly a 1 to 3 minute
recovery time,
where we can promote
these replicas to
become read and writable
to serve application traffic
in the event of an outage.
It allows you to build a
database configuration that
adheres to fairly strict RPO
and RTO objectives, or recovery
time objectives, rather, in
case of a widespread or regional
outage.
One thing to note
here is the replicas
themselves are always readable.
So you are able, not
only to see which
data has landed
on your replicas,
but if you have use cases such
as reporting, or maybe you just
want to offer lower
latency reads to users
in other parts of the world,
cross region replicas are
a good way to go
to accomplish that.
To wrap up here, we
want to recommend
that for especially critical
systems in your environment
with Cloud SQL, you enable
automatic daily backups,
and point-in-time
recovery for very
granular or millisecond
level recovery.
You should also
consider taking more
frequent on-demand backups.
These can be useful
if you're making
for example, a schema change.
You may want to take
an on demand backup
just before you make
the schema change.
Of course,
point-in-time recovery
can be used to perform
that restoration as well,
but it never hurts to
take an additional backup,
especially when you
know you're going
to be making a big change.
Next, we encourage you to enable
in region high availability
or synchronous
replication models.
The Cloud SQL can health
check your instances,
can automatically failover
in the event of an incident,
and make sure that
you're back online
without any intervention.
And lastly, consider
using in region,
or more importantly, cross
region replication, which
is asynchronous
replication, to make
sure you have a
near real time copy
of your data in another
region then where
your primary instance resides.
That way in case of a
regional failure or disaster,
you have a near real
time copy of data
that can be made accessible
quite rapidly adhering
to a fairly strict RTO.
With that, I
encourage you to tune
into two additional
sessions, first
being data modernization,
which is McKesson's story
of their migration to cloud.
And then take a look
at our bare metal
solution, which helps
you bring your enterprise
workloads to GCP.
If you want to see the showcase
that I mentioned inaction,
please follow this link, and
play our wack-a-mole style,
high availability demo.
Lastly, try it out for yourself.
Get hands on with Cloud SQL by
following our quick lab quest.
You'll be introduced to a number
of Cloud SQL's capabilities,
including those that
I mentioned today.
And by the end, you'll be
quite familiar with Cloud SQL.
With that, I want to thank
you for joining me today
for this session.
As mentioned, I'm available
for expert sessions
as part of Google
Cloud Next to 2020.
And I look forward
to meeting you.
Thank you.